[Music]
the Waimakariri district council meeting
for December was recently held and
before getting down to business the
councillors and Mayor David Ayres had
the pleasure of presenting a community
service award to kuiper resident John
Rose John was recognized for his
volunteer efforts in the community
including his work with North Canterbury
minibus trust
the council then moved on to deputations
in presentations and heard from both
Andrew Gough a resident of Swannanoa and
developer Bevan homes on the proposal to
reduce a section of tram Road from 100
kilometers per hour to 80 kilometers per
hour
after considerable debate council
approved the recommendation that the
speed limit be reduced from 100
kilometers per hour to 80 kilometers per
hour on tram Road from 500 meters east
of the Bradley's Road McHugh's Road
intersection to 300 meters west of that
intersection
council also approved an expansion of
options to the curbside collection
service to be added into the waste
management in minimization plan 2017
after a large amount of public
consultation option C has been chosen as
the preferred option which allows users
a choice of new rates funded Burnsville
rubbish in organics or sticking with the
user pays rubbish bags and rates funded
recycling than they currently use the
final details of the proposed new
curbside collection service will be
presented to the council and the final
draft waste minimization plan next year
after the 2018 - 2028 long term plan has
been approved council also adopted the
northern Pegasus Bay bylaw 2016
implementation plan which includes the
establishment of the northern Pegasus
Bay advisory group this group will be
chaired by councillor L Blakey and
council approved the legal stopping and
physical removal of Hood Avenue and
Clark Avenue in the pines beach area the
removal of these now redundant roads is
another step forward and the
regeneration process
this meeting was the last for the year
with councils first ordinary meeting in
the new year on Tuesday 6th of February
[Music]